an a então você tá aqui né se você está
ouvindo o que eu tô falando agora você
acabou de se você acabou de abrir se
você acabou de abrir você acabou de meu
deus você acabou de abrir esse vídeo
agora está ouvindo eu tô falando tá
olhando pra mim agora clique em gostei
por agora pelo amor de deus eu tenho que
ficar lembrando porque se eu não falo
você não clica aceitar pelo celular você
quer pelo computador pelo tablet pela tv
não sei vai aqui embaixo e clique em
gostei eu já expliquei vou explicar no
ano 6 kessy clicar em gostei este site é
que entende que você não quer mais
assistir você fica sem saber quando saí
de novo e não recebe a notificação para
isso acontecer clicar nessa bosta nesse
gostei então beleza explicou beleza
beleza se inscreve no canal aí então
cair sei lá eu estou no meu cabelo novo
em meio à vontadinha no jardim qat olha
é realmente eu achei país tudo boa noite
lambo que faz tempo que eu apareça aqui
pessoas estão pedindo a fibra um
procedimento estético tanque poph lã
número dente hoje é tão parte é só uma
permuta todos têm algumas pessoas
acharam exagerando então eu não sei eu
acho que sim enquanto o engenheiro
professor tem mais é o pai do
procedimento e pedicure colocava
permanecência ou não a do tanque
colocando falou olha o dólar depois de
lana não pode fazer o que quiser pode
cometer boss tanque no amarelo o seu
dentinho lennon foi entregue coloca essa
invenção de como eu gosto eu cheguei e
falei olha que eu nem vou falar com o
meu gosto daqui de olhar a falar maluco
e aí galera show no canal tudo com vocês
agora sim é de vocês
o último show do ano no dia 8 de
dezembro votar em taboão da serra aqui
em são paulo 9 de dezembro são caetano
do sul aqui em são paulo 10 de dezembro
e tuiuiú tábua minas gerais 13 de
dezembro e tubia goiás 14 de dezembro
goianésia goiás 15 de dezembro porto
seguro na bahia 16 de dezembro jequié na
bahia 17 de dezembro e itabuna na bahia
e morreu bahia pra encerrou-se quem
quiser comprar ingresso para os últimos
jogos do ano nem sei quando volto a
fazer show nem sei se volto mais fazer
show neste site que se você quiser
comprar a chegar o aniversário do meu
pai aniversário lá em casa é uma [ __ ]
tão grande mesmo
bom parece sim eu não sei quando
diferente do adversário e rico
aniversário bola começar pela ida à
universal o rico em um aniversário é
lindo demais na hora de amanhã olha o
menino meu deus como tá lindo meu dia
chegar onde o labor olha pra você sim de
terninho muse o painel quem que amos pra
paris com nossos paire brincado com il e
seu pai brincávamos na grama como duas
crianças
a nota também não vão querer um padre de
família quando ouvem caged que a rede se
encolhe na mãe olha o quanto o pobre
impune versário antes aí já viu logo seu
irmão silver pedindo vai apanhar no meio
do universo que é apanhado no meio
universal ea mãe sabe que a criança não
quer apanhar mas ela pergunta pra ter
certeza quer apanhar no meio do
aniversário não né
ótimo a decoração é nessa comemoração do
aniversário da atração universal do rico
o receptivo é que são pessoas bem
vestidas para receber a levar a pessoa
fale tudo se metem na sopa servir por
tiro de seda a decoração aniversário por
tudo que sobrou dos outros aniversário
vai ver o bolo vela uma de um formato 7
jardim eo time quebrado emendou do
vocabulário pobre existe negócio de
estar se dá para usar não é descartada
lá em casa tem para descartar de
aniversário de 6 anos nega o prato leva
um prato pronto sacudiu taboãozinho novo
isso quando boto bom diretamente do
guardanapo entrega pessoa que a economia
superaqueça colher ea economia o que eu
tenho um ótimo eu recebo um golo só no
guardanapo não ficou pior porque ôôô o
recheio do bolo ele molha o guardanapo e
aí você como você não sabe se está
comendo papel o guarda na besta mãe
determine comeu bolo só sobre isso aqui
de banana passa o resto foi tudo também
o garçom garçom garçom aniversário pode
partir de ti se pode ter pouco no dia do
aniversário aparece os 15
já já que você já comeu o bolo bolo do
rica 3 andar aquela coisa bonita sim os
suns banda aniversário domingo rio
parece um bolo de casamento o bolso do
pobre do pop podiam dormir mal ter o
primeiro andar segue abaixo o bicho
rasteiros é claro botar o recheio que já
é fim eles cortam no meio levanta bota
doce de goiaba no meio encaixe de novo
ontem eu deixei ateus que inventou de
fazer um desenho fazer
a picape avaí pega o negócio aqui foi um
negócio sei quando chega a pessoa que
roubou fala meu deus que massa decoração
de satanás agora de filme de terror
balão como é que abalam da festa do rio
de gás hélio do dólar em cima até mechem
sol dubai a máquina se bota o balão onde
ele vai
o menino brinca com gás hélio que eu ele
é mamãe aqui é bom
volta normal até o grupo a na boca vai
pagar ágio o balão baluchi médio
o balão cair ricos e chegou a pensar
como é que falam tanto no formato do
mickey aquela coisa bonita quando não
tem como informar uma escultura em balão
porque ele compra um saco de cada curva
aniversário pode ser acertado nada
esperando prático salgado ps que não
termine história no balão que o menino
do pop quando ele vai na festa de
aniversário não vai na intenção de
comemorar a intenção de destruir em
quebrava colherzinha caramba poder furar
um balão cair nas graças da hora que o
filho rico não chega o aniversário chega
com que um presente o fim do papo cheio
o aniversário chega com que uma vasilha
e até considera votação para atingir
bola de forma rápida a mãe eo recurso
vai entregar o presente que chegou
aquela cachoeira grande diz assim olha
eu vi que ele gostava muito de
videogames então eu cumpri e simples em
2018 né e quero que ele se divirta
também comprei esse box com todos os
jogos da marvel o wigan em casa de artes
civil pente goiano não é gay ae em abril
quero ver você 2 turbo que entrega o
presente é a valorização lembrancinha tá
e saibam ver a cara de desgosto da
pessoa quando abri a comida aniversário
recall memória parece um casamento
comigo pra cá e vai pegar o que quiser
fazer falta no adversário o papel da boa
mesa de doces e não pode pegar um
brigadeiro que não diz completa só
depois
parabéns é um suspense que a de maria a
comida toda hora certa primeiro vem a
pipoca e por um creme de galinha uma
rodada de cachorro quente refrigerante é
bom você esteja ali na hora que está
distribuindo essas coisas que se você
não tiver na hora perdeu não volta mas
não na época cantava final do creme de
galinha não um ataque e nem toque na
opinião de galinha não a mãe também não
ocorra eu também no final de tudo é o
bolo agora porque fecha de rico e pobre
têm em comum que eu não consigo entender
é aquele balão cheio de balinha que ele
se pendura a pátria se estourar caiu
bumbum no chão me começa a pegar aquela
linha é a parte da diversão dos adultos
que havia usado testando poder de guerra
das crianças que o pai pensa assim para
ver quantos amigo meu filho vai matar
por um pirulito na festa henrique se
despede é cada um tem sua culpa fazer
vai começar quando vago as pessoas vão
embora vai ficando menos gente menos em
nosso muito obrigado pelo convite tá é
bom já está morrendo de sono que agiu a
jogar em casa no sofá pb língua
reconhecendo proíbem escola também já
tomei três atos de mim estou louca já
não tem pra cá o papa embora é uma luta
que o menino cair no chão bola na hora
para se dar bem eo menino a marisa
também enganar nem na omc em um não vai
falar embora que amanhã alumínio começa
a rolar no chão com cara de menino
enquanto os pais estão conversando para
se despedir do irmão em cristo é para
catalá mãe conversando com a outra mãe
fã pois é muito obrigada viu tanques
equipa desculpando e qualquer coisa que
pobre é pobre de verdade quando sai da
casa da visita ele fala assim vai
desculpando aí qualquer coisa nessa
conversa que você olha pra mim está
assim a droga
não não há a mãe começa a existir aqui
já viu o cara de mãe querem desistir da
criança à mãe faz aqui embora menos que
alguém naquele momento faz assim posso
ficar amanhã pode confiar não agrediu
que tudo isso ainda que não ia clicar em
gostei no vídeo não andou dão bom uso
público em góis ea en 112 que gostei não
esquece clicar em gosto de aproveitar
agora que você viu fazendo isso vai no
botãozinho que gostei clica eu quero
você comente aqui embaixo que você acha
mais engraçado no aniversário tamo junto
é nóis valeu e ryan